COMMITTEE OF JANUARY --
SO WELCOME TO EVERYONE I THINK
WE HAD ONE IN DECEMBER SO WE ALL
GOT TO BE TOGETHER.
AND AS A NEW GROUP --
BUT WE'RE HERE ACTUALLY WITH
WORK TO DO TODAY --
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA.
AND I AM HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN
MOTIONS BUT I WANT TO TELL YOU
WE NEED TO TAKE ITEM NUMBER ONE
FIRST.
BY WHAT I WOULD ASK IS WE GO
THROUGH ITEM ONE ITEM TO ITEM
THREE AND THEN I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
A AN ITEM FOR THREE SEVEN THAT
WAY IT'S CLEANER GIVEN THE KINDS
OF ITEMS WE ARE DEALING WITH
TODAY.
AND SO ON ITEM NUMBER ONE IT IS
PROBABLY OUR MOST IMPORTANT ITEM
WELL THEY'RE ALL IMPORTANT.
BUT APPOINT THE TEARS IN MEMBERS
OF THE STANDING COMMITTEES FOR
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY REGULAR
SESSION.
THANK YOU ARE.
MADAM CHAIR I MEAN MADAM
SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS GROWTH.
MINING.
MONNING AYE ROTH.
ROTH I WILL.
WILK AYE ATKINS SITE AND IDEAS I
THINK YOU IS AS ARE.
OTHER MEMBERS COMING AND WE'RE
VOTING ON ITEM NUMBER ONE WHICH
HOPEFULLY IS NOT --
CONTROVERSY --
IN YOUR MIND IT'S THE APPOINT
THE CHAIRS AND MEMBERS OF THE
STANDING COMMITTEES --
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
REGULAR SESSION I THANK YOU NO
WORRIES I FIGURED YOU WERE GOOD
ON THAT --
ONE SO THANK YOU --
ZERO FIVE ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
SO ITEM NUMBER TWO IS THE JOINT
COMMITTEE APPOINTMENTS AND IT
WOULD BE TO APPOINT SENATOR ROTH
AS VICE CHAIR SENATORS PORCHES
TO ROSS SO.
HERTZBERG MONNING MORE LIKE AN
WIENER AS MEMBERS OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE
FEELING ALL VACANCIES.
SO MOVED THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIR MADAM SECRETARY SENATORS
GROWTH.
GROVE AYE MONNING MONNING AYE
ROTH.
ROTH AYE WILK WILK AYE ATKINS
AYE AT CONSIGNEE.
THANK YOU THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FIVE ZERO THE THIRD ITEM.
IS THE SUBCOMMITTEE
RATIFICATIONS IT'S THE REQUEST
FROM A SENATOR MITCHELL AS CHAIR
OF BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE. TO RATIFY THE
FOLLOWING SUBCOMMITTEE AND
APPOINTMENTS --
WHICH YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU
IT IS ALL OF THE VARIOUS
SUBCOMMITTEES AND I WOULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OUR I'M TRUSTING YOU HEARD WHO
MADE THE MOTION ABOUT MONNING
OKAY ARE MADAM SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL.
SENATORS GROWTH --
FIVE MONNING MONNING AYE ROSS.
ROSS I WILL.
WILK AYE ATKINS ATKINS I IT'S
FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO THANK YOU SO
MUCH ARE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES WE HAVE
FLORA KNOWLEDGE MEN SWITCHER
ITEMS FOUR THROUGH.
SEVEN HOPEFULLY YOU'VE HAD A
CHANCE TO LOOK AT THAT THAT'S A
REGULAR.
I THINK YOU WILL SEE ON THE
AGENDA EVERY SESSION.
HAVE YOU TO THANK YOU MISTER
ROSS R. MADAM SECRETARY.
SENATORS GROWTH GROW BY MONNING
MONEY AYE ROTH.
ROTH AYE WILK.
WILK AYE ATKINS.
INSIDE.
HERO FIVE ZERO THOUGH THOSE
REQUIRE --
EXECUTIVE SESSION AND I WILL
JUST LET PEOPLE KNOW THIS THIS
MEETING IS GONE QUICK SO FAR IT
WILL NOT BE THE CASE IN THE
FUTURE AS WE HAVE.
ACTUAL CONFIRMATIONS TO DO --
BUT WITH THAT I WILL --
AND TURN INTO EXECUTIVE SESSION
AND WAIT ON OF FOLKS TO LEAVE
THE ROOM BEFORE WE GET STARTED